- [Voiceover] All right, part c.
What time t, where zero
is less than or equal to t
is less than or equal to eight,
is the amount of water
in the pipe at a minimum?
Justify your answer.
All right, well, let's define a function w
that represents the amount
of water in the pipe
at anytime, t, and then
we could figure out how
to figure out the minimum
value for w over that interval.
So let's just say w of t.
So that's the amount of water in the pipe
at any given time, t.
It's going to be equal to, well,
we start with 30 cubic feet
of water in the pipe that t equals zero
that tells us that right up here.
So we start with that much.
And then we are going to add
or take away some amount.
So then it's going to be plus.
We're going to sum up
from time zero to time t.
Remember this is the function of t.
Well, let's sum up our net inflow
times little small changes in time.
We will sum up all those
small changes in time
from zero to t and that will
give us our aggregate inflow
or aggregate net inflow.
So what is our net inflow?
Well, you have the function R which says
the rate which the water is
entering and your function d
which is the rate which water is exiting.
Instead of using t as our variable,
I'm going to use x since t is
already one of our variable,
is one of our boundaries of integration.
We can use any variable we want.
It's really just a bit
of a placeholder variable
for the integration.
So our net inflow is
R, I'll say R of x
minus D of x
and then dx.
Once again, this is
our net rate of inflow.
This is our inflow minus our outflow
so our net rate of inflow
times small changes,
we could view this as
time although it's x,
and then we sum up from zero to time
is equal to t.
So this is how much water
we are going to have
in the pipe at any time t.
So let's now think about at what point
does w hit a minimum in the central.
And there's three possibilities
where w could hit a minimum point.
It could hit a minimum
at right at the beginning
at each at w of zero.
It could hit it at the end of our interval
at w of eight at t equals eight
or it could be some place in between
where w is at a local maximum point.
In which case, the derivative
of w will be equal to zero.
So let's first evaluate
w at the end points.
So w of zero.
Oh, we know that.
That's the boundary of a zero to zero
that they gave it to us in the problem
is the initial state is
we have 30 cubic feet
of water in the pipe already.
And now, what is w of eight?
Well, this is going to be 30
plus the definite integral
from zero to eight
of R of x minus D of x,
minus D of x, dx.
And lucky for us, we're
allowed to use a calculator
so let's use a calculator
to evaluate this.
And so, let me get my calculator out.
Let me go see the
definition of R of x, D of x
right over here so I can type them in.
And what I'm gonna do
and there's a bunch of ways
of more advance you get
with a calculator that
might save you some time
in front of the AP test.
I'm actually gonna define a function
that is R of x minus D of x.
So everywhere I see t,
I'm gonna substitute it.
I'm gonna use x instead.
And then I could use that later on
to integrate it or to
solve it in some way.
So let's do that.
So y1 is gonna be 20
times sine
of x squared
divided by 35,
close parenthesis,
minus open parenthesis.
You have negative 0.04
times t to the third power
or sorry, so I'll write times x,
x to the third power
plus 0.4
times x squared
plus 0.96
times x.
And then I can close these parentheses.
So does that make sense?
20 times sine of x squared
divided by 35 minus negative 0.04
x to the third plus 0.4
x squared plus 0.96 times x.
All right, there you go.
I have defined y1.
And now I can use that to
evaluate different things.
So let me now go back here.
And so let me evaluate
what this is going to be.
This is going to be 30
plus the definitive role
of the math functions.
You scroll down a little bit.
You have, this is the function
for definite integral,
function integral.
The function is y1
and I can go to vars.
I'm gonna get my y vars.
It's gonna be a function variable.
So y1 is what I select.
I could have typed it in but
this will hopefully save time
and I can reuse y1.
And my variable integration is x.
I'm going from zero to eight.
From my lower bound is zero.
My upper bound is eight.
Let's see, did I type everything in?
All right.
And I'm gonna munch a little bit.
And there you have it.
It's approximately 48.544
cubic feet of water at t equals eight.
So let me write that,
48.544.
So this is
approximately
48.544 cubic feet.
And now let's see if
there's any point in between
where w hits a local maximum point
or a local minimum point I should say.
I think I said a local maximum earlier on.
I should say a local minimum point.
And so if it's at a local
or maximum point really,
the derivative of w is going to be zero.
So let's see, at what t do
we get a zero derivative?
So w prime of t.
Well, the derivative or a
constant with respect to t is zero
and the derivative of
this with respect to t
and this comes from the
fundamental theorem of calculus,
this is going to be R of t
minus D of t.
Well, once again, this is a function.
We have t as the upper bound.
And so we have whatever
here that we are integrating
but it is now going to be a function of t.
And so in order for this
to be equal to zero,
we have to figure out when does
R of t minus D of t equals zero.
And lucky for us, we've already typed in
R of t minus D of t.
We defined that as y sub
one on our calculator.
So let's go back here.
And now I can use the Solver.
So go to math
and then let's see if I scroll up.
Let's see or this is, I get to the Solver.
I could have scrolled down as well.
It's right below definite integral.
So I go to the Solver.
And I say the equation zero equals,
and I could just go to y1.
So go to my y variables, function.
I select y1.
So in my equation is equal to y1.
And I press Enter.
And now I could put an initial guess
for what x value is going
to solve that equation.
Usually a t value but I'm
using x as a variable here.
And now I do alpha and
I quickly solve here.
So a little blue you see
right above the Enter.
And it gets to,
well, zero is one of them.
Let's see if I can get another one.
So let's see if I can get,
let's see if I started two, alpha,
solve, what it munch on that a little bit.
Okay, so this is actually
within the interval.
So approximately
3.272.
So t is approximately
That's where we have a local minimum point
but now we have to evaluate w there.
So we have to evaluate w
at 3.272
to figure out if it's truly lower
than w zero.
W of eight is higher than w of zero.
So, how do we do that?
Well, luckily, we can go back.
So second quit.
And that should be stored
into the variable x.
Yep, it's right there.
So then we can say, well, let's calculate.
We wanna calculate the function evaluated
when t is 3.272.
So our function is 30
plus the definite integral.
Go to the math.
So definite integral.
Once again, we have y1.
So let me go to my y
variables, function, y1.
We already defined that
as R of x minus D of x.
Our variable of integration is x.
Our lower bound is zero
and our upper bound
is 3.272
we've restored in the variable x.
So we can actually,
it's a little confusing.
This is saying what's
our variable integration.
This is the actual variable.
This is actual value for upper bound.
And so let's munch on it a little bit
and we get 27.965.
So this is approximately equal to
27.965.
So now we're ready to answer.
At what time t is the amount of water
in the pipe at a minimum?
We can see that at time
3.272,
we have less water in the pipe
than either right when we started
or right at the end of our interval
at t equals eight.
So, at what time t?
We say t is equal to 3.272.
We could write w of 3.272
is less than w of zero
which is less than w of eight.
So this indeed just by knowing
the derivative of the zero,
it could be a minimum or maximum.
But the fact that it's lower
than both of the end points,
this tells us that,
hey, this is a minimum,
minimum point
right over there
or we could say that t equals 3.272
is where we hit out minimum value.